[Music]
nestled in the tissues of your neck is a
small unassuming organ that wields
enormous power over your body it's
called the thyroid like the operations
manager in a company its role is to make
sure that the cells in your body are
working properly it does that by using
hormones to deliver messages to every
single one of them this high ranking
organ is made up of lobules
that each contain smaller cells called
follicles which store the hormones the
thyroid sends out into your blood two of
the most important hormones it produces
are thyroxine and triiodothyronine or t3
and t4 as messengers the hormones job is
to instruct every cell in the body when
to consume oxygen and nutrients that
maintains the body's metabolism the
series of reactions our cells perform to
provide us with energy this hormonal
notification from the thyroid gets the
heart pumping more efficiently and makes
our cells break down nutrients faster
when you need more energy
the thyroid helps by sending out
hormones to increase metabolism
ultimately the thyroid allows our cells
to use energy grow and reproduce the
thyroid is controlled by the pituitary
gland a hormonal gland deep in the brain
that oversees the thyroids tasks making
sure it knows when to send out its
messengers the pituitary's role is to
sense if hormone levels in the blood are
too low or too high in which case it
sends out instructions in the form of
the thyroid stimulating hormone even in
this tightly controlled system however
management sometimes slips up certain
diseases growths in the thyroid or
chemical imbalances in the body can
confuse the organ and make it death to
the pituitary's guiding commands
the first problem this causes is
hyperthyroidism which happens when the
organ sends out too many hormones that
means the cells are overloaded with
instructions to consume nutrients and
oxygen they become overactive as a
result meaning a person with
hyperthyroidism experiences a higher
metabolism signaled by a faster
heartbeat constant hunger and rapid
weight loss they also feel hot sweaty
anxious and find it difficult to sleep
the opposite problem is hypothyroidism
which happens when the thyroid sends out
too few hormones meaning the body's
cells don't have as many messengers to
guide them in response cells grow
listless and metabolism slows people
with hypothyroidism see symptoms in
weight gain sluggishness sensitivity to
cold swollen joints and feeling low
luckily there are medical treatments
that can help trigger the thyroids
activities again and bring the body back
to a steady metabolic rate for such a
little organ the thyroid wields an awful
lot of power but a healthy thyroid
manages ourselves so effectively that it
can keep us running smoothly without us
even noticing it's there
[Music]
you